what was the story with Matthew
McConaughey didn't you get I know what
was [ __ ] to me there was a shot a movie
together shot of me together fake-ass
Hollywood we right now in the Harmony
Korine yeah fake ass we something like
[ __ ] that so me and him first day on the
sing so I'm smoking some real weed like
in the scene yeah he like man just make
sure they know real we cuz you know I
got you Matthew it's all good
ten minutes later this [ __ ]
store rapping his line was director
angry with you for tricking men and why
does Matthew McConaughey handle Fame so
well like what is it he does he just he
just is a skill it's like when you the
way you handle kids the way you handle
them I'm not just people the way you
handle adversity the way you keep a
smile on your face the way you just he
made me feel comfortable right and it's
like usually I make you feel comfortable
yeah you give them something reversed if
you flip it on me and I come to set and
you got me comfortable you got me in a
zone okay and are you dealing with the
fans and you dealing with this and I'm
watching his skill is crap yeah well we
out and about